assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullah wa
better care to brothers and sisters
welcome back to our mobile chat show
this off first show I'm up north today
and this is the area where I used to
live basically and I've got two guests
with me these bubbles are basically the
one on my left is one of the brothers
that I met half stuck on me I met the
first few nights right yeah
and then you moved up north and I'm
alaikum yeah you were on it yeah hello
that's usually told this here ya talking
voice yeah toilets all around there so
yeah he was one of the first Madrid
first I met we should do rap him
together why wasn't it a rapper you know
just just just missing a bus missing
about yes I'm just used to think you as
a rapper yeah you used to rattle I could
remember you used to sell me some of
your some of the stuff you used to do is
quite good actually
I always get her out but you know I'm
just yeah but this is the brother who
basically told me about Islam and he
wants to be stay anonymous don't need
you know those intentions he does want
to be corrupt we all avoid him for that
but this is the Brahman who gave me Dawa
you know this is the man and this isn't
why I wanted to do the show is because I
wanted to show you the importance of
Dawa he didn't he conveyed the message
I'll open hearts you know we don't we
don't go there and make people become a
Muslim only Allah Allah Allah Tala I was
once on a wheels it will happen but the
reason I did this video is basically
because it's a show to show you guys
basically look a simple tower conveying
a message to your neighbor your friend
your work colleague look how it can
change you can translate all praises
belong to Allah sport Allah
so this brother who using him to convey
any message because what happened first
I used to come to your flat right we
looked on the road yes when we first
meet on road what do you see many on the
show I don't want to talk
a sip ruff I mean I literally linked you
on road brah yeah and then wirele it was
literally it was literally a roadside to
his slab yeah I mean so big up or the
roadside that it's la man going in I'm
about these easily pick him up man I've
seen what they're doing and they going
in hard
yeah mashallah is good and then weapon
was I would always go to your flat in it
we could like use it sure after work and
then he used to kick back wish to chill
out you know yeah nice to talk about
stuff even-even from way back then
before you came to the real Islam yeah
you believed in God bro yeah and I
wasn't believed in a creator yeah yeah I
mean you just didn't know which
direction to go with exactly behind me
and back then I didn't even know what a
lo he was yeah and I mean I didn't even
know about the Halloween yeah
until you started telling me about yeah
and I was quite amazed by amazed about
how corrupt it wasn't in a way really
generally but personally I didn't really
believe in a my mom would buy kind of my
mom always believed that God is well but
regarded others I didn't make sense
because I was like okay you believe you
won't follow anybody Alone's way but you
don't follow you come again see so he
didn't really make sense but that's what
was really baffled but that's when you
were now go to your friend you show me
these videos of the scientific miracles
in the Quran and videos of Almighty God
and that kind of kicked off didn't it
but what used to get me as well yeah
it's like all these people
from these other sections that say they
believe in Ali or they follow Ali here
but I'll use to follow our prophet you
know I mean so it's like if you follow
Ali you need to follow the Rasool that
mean yeah exactly so this is what used
to confuse me as well when I first found
out about Halloween
yeah yes obviously I didn't even know
but I will be back there
hmm yeah so that was neat to me as well
yeah that's what you said and that's
what me and Matt sometimes will be in
Morrowind house mara was basically our
hairdresser I he would a car and yeah we
statue and that's when I go into the
happier watching
Amuro needs to talk about her law's work
yeah he did and now that's why it's
hardly surroundings and even though
sometimes I'll go to pray often not only
who you but I wrote a planner to pray
while just going with the flow like I
just I didn't want to do it remember the
first time he came to pray with me wrong
did you choke me to this one lose today
didn't it that mosque we went today for
our Eid prayer yeah that's the first
time we come first time he came to pray
with you yes was when we went to pray
the taraweeh yeah oh my gosh you know I
was into that last time we pray yeah you
prayed twenty record straight
was it 20/20 Rucker no I can remember oh
and also that was just the other day
your legs are in it is a terribly I
thought that you prayed the four ax-cut
fun yeah good I mean we prayed this
three rocket whittler after yeah I
didn't know what I mean though I'll just
go with the flow but not be anything you
got scared that day bro yeah but you
know why my legs were aching here cuz no
I'm you know the way you sit down here
and it's tunnel wheel can you imagine me
I'll just these guys come to me yeah
let's go pray and I'm thinking yeah
let's just go 25 minutes in it I was
actually laughing you know I mean
because this is first time he prayed and
the first time he prays man was praying
Todd I'm talking over an hour prayed 20
rock-cut yeah and I we yeah right and
then prayed a shot as well you know
yeah climbing each other we fight that
are we I don't know what's going on clue
the water yeah I mean uneven it was you
got scared that day brother get scared
you talk about worried that day because
I thought I scared you yeah cuz you know
what I put too much pressure at once in
it yeah exactly what and that was one of
the things like sometimes you give tacos
as a revert sometimes you think you know
what I'm scared to ask this or if I say
this that's why I would have a lot
misconceptions in my idea but I wouldn't
tell no one I just say you know what
he'll find out myself but Allah
the thing about dellwo people need to
understand about Dawa yeah it's like you
said at the beginning of the video RUF
is people need to understand that our
job yeah isn't to yeah isn't to convert
people yeah yeah that's what's to tell
people it's at the end of the day we
believe is the tree the message should I
mean if we believe this is the truth
that's the right way obviously this what
we want for our friends and family the
right way so we're just trying our best
to give advice and give given what we
think is the best advice and for me the
message it's up to them if they if they
fell off as their heart yeah it's as
simple as that
if the Creator yeah chooses them to
accept it or not you know right so
really we have no power that over who's
gonna become what you know I mean yeah
at the end of the day for if God the
Creator the Almighty if he wanted to he
could have made the whole world on him
he could have made the whole word
Christian or Jew hmm I mean or Sikh or
Hindu yeah but he didn't he made
everyone different at the end of the day
for a reason yeah of course and that's
what this is this was his importance of
Dawa is this is how important is guys
but if I wasn't nudge so come on money
be no quiet yeah I'm listening no I'm
doesn't any money you guys talking how
was that before though
like what kind of what what kind of the
person was that before however many yeah
you had a special thing in you but I
feel special
yeah like you know you wanted to do
something you was gonna do something
like your shirt oh but you just try out
the hood problem yeah he was but he just
seemed away good so get all your vision
what was it ghetto youth by yes yeah
it's just cause we still get no reason
mean yeah absolutely so get into a lot
of fight stuff like that and it was
wrong bodies that's how I would yeah
it's to get a lot of people can remember
those same things reporting about me
night yeah we looking at hey that's not
anyone anyone you know anyone
we looking at are you looking at you
know even if I wasn't looking then April
yeah now you're now you're humble should
I mean you don't do that now bro yeah
now even if they look at you you smile
at them yeah what'd you tell you know
you know for the reverts people that
coming to Islam
how should a Muslim treat them because I
didn't they you look you gave me bit a
dollar here but do you think it's just
about Dow of the mouth for the actions
obviously actions speak louder than
words
I mean sometimes it's not about it's not
about what we say it's about what we do
what we do do not mean it for something
because people see things I mean you've
got a ways that you've got a would you
call it rough you got a given example
you got to make an example of it you
know I mean obviously you're stuck on
what I call and I know you trying to
straight off my head but you've got this
you've got to set the example yourself I
mean if people see because actions speak
louder than the double you know that but
sometimes we do go out and about the
streets but when we go to pray how
important we get a lot of people like
steering right it can really increase
that interested I wanna get when you get
people saying are this person is bad
because it's that religion but this
person is bad because of that and how
are these people going to come to Islam
exactly if if we're dissonant should I
mean it'll be like we've got to be nice
to everyone and show them yet this is
what it's like this is what this is why
we're Muslim yeah I mean doesn't matter
what you are what you believe in see on
a serious note view rough yeah you use
like like I said my views and he was a
good man always been a good man who was
at the good heart
Iman has changed a bit I can so
basically and I mean he was he was a bit
like a wannabe gangster rough to be
honest everyone know it but is one of
you trying to be something that you're
not and I was deaf I just because of
maybe a racism that I used to go through
here and what doesn't work it doesn't
help with like the film's the music TV
promoting it glamorizing Asian I mean
yeah because as huge we wanna we want to
be the big man on road you know I mean
and that's why I linked you about the
first time I linked jr. was on road
exactly you know I mean like I said at
the beginning of the video it was
literally roadside to his lung I'm a
bucket but but she is gonna Salaam
because they do great work as well I
think that's what it was man I met you
on the road you know it's like a
roadside it's not so pick up you got
roadside a slum me that what about him
so you know I mean we doing work
or do you were doing you know me but all
I'm saying is yeah I don't want to get
picked up for nothing from here because
I'm pretty because I can nothing we
everything done time line up you can you
can you can try and make someone a
Muslim the entire life they won't come
to Islam unless I love when something is
fun last one is true gentleman
one of my friends one of my mates he
became a Muslim and I never even tried
to make up honestly I never even tried
to convert all I used to do used to ask
me questions I had a nice to tell him
stuff you know I mean and that's how we
came to his club you know you know I
always used to come see you so can I be
honest my brother cuz it does Cory's mom
but there was a knife Curry's so
obviously I had to make an excuse to
come and see you rough
there aren't any we burn the curry
chicken buna listen bro a loser don't
bring the car into it bro seriously if I
let me be with you yeah akari was on
point
brother don't make me bring it that you
didn't make me that cross today from
from don't make me bring your dad's
don't a kebab on pizza birthday to me I
will slap you with a pizza bread you
know brother do you ever make dwell
famille when you give me the whole story
should make dua for you brother
yeah that's always invite you to come to
Gemma with me and everything but back
then he wasn't ready for him but hundred
you are now broth I mean I'm look at you
not rocking I mean your Iman know your
Iman you're my family
Bravo Iman is stronger than miner
masha'Allah Allah knows them you know I
mean only Allah knows that I know the
humble not always big that I know it is
only Alice Montana mean I'm not trying
to make her that but you're looking at
out a period I was in this summer I'm
not trying to make her yeah that are
more mr. perfect no I mean we all cause
since I mean and sometimes what about
you telling about people sometimes the
calamities and the sin I don't know
correct me if I'm wrong can be a
blessing but it was a pleasure having
you on the show man thank you very much
obviously that I said before my rebirth
story and food is going to come out soon
we had a bit of a voice problem with it
but inshallah will be out soon put your
questions anything that you want to ask
down on the comments below will give
shout outs as well
Salam alaikum and if you want a little
bro
peace to everyone you know I mean
somewhat equal to the whole world